just some Waters please and a Turkish
coffee please Cola Cola zero please am I
supposed to be boycotting in this video
the COA your drinks are zero you are
zero tomorrow if you're even fasting may
Allah kill you with
that these are some of the drinks in my
fridge guys just some of them so that we
drink along water and many other things
many fruits to pick from many foods to
eat from Subhan Allah what about the
people who are starving in Gaza all
around the world who do not have food to
eat how can we make these drinks these
foods go down our throat knowing that
they're starving I am working with the
one my charity for the food project guys
and they are a 100% donation policy
charity I know the brothers who run the
charity and I have full trust in them
that the prophet P said the Muslim is
not the one when his neighbor is hungry
his stomach is
full brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well so
brother and sisters I did not want to do
this video cuz I already done a video
about FIS and about sne thing but I was
absolutely shocked as you guys will be
shocked as much as me I thought this
clip was taken off the stream like it
happened before the stream started so he
ordered his Coca-Cola with a smug on his
face joking like it's fun you cannot
make this up bro just just think about
second your brother and sisters been
massacred babies blown into pieces and
the um Has Come Together boycotting
certain products Etc Coca-Cola is one
but no no no we knew his situation like
you know where he stands anyways let Al
condemn Israel yeah but he casually this
is not of camera by the way this was on
the stream I was shocked it's like you
look at Israel and what they do it's
like can these people get any worse and
he's like wow yes they do the same with
this person this individual it is
unbelievable look at his attitude this
is a person of knowledge yeah he looks
like a she look at him and compare him
to sne who's a new Muslim who is a new
Muslim character character this is what
the prophet said I've come for nothing
but to perfect good character character
look at sneo and compare it to this
individual please tell me who
has um more better character look at
sn's response to Coca-Cola he could have
just be like you know actually yeah you
know no no no he's stuck to his guns you
know sneo seems like he's a man of
principle I saw that in him but it is
becoming more and more apparent watch
this video now no I'm okay for now wa
eat after yeah because just some Waters
please and a Turkish coffee please tur
coffee want Turkish coffee Cola Cola
zero please am I supposed to be
boycotting in this video oh come
on of course you get cola man I didn't
even pick up on that sta
Turkish coffee and Coke Zero Coke Zero
yeah thanks Turkish coffee for me no
Coke for me I'm
boycotting tomorrow if you're even
fasting may Allah kill you with
that the filthiest of people two types
did you did you see that yeah it's just
like yeah you know I was supposed to I
was supposed to boycot okay yeah Coca
Cola zero for me you're a zero bro the
Coca-Cola your drinks are zero you are a
zero you've become a zero in everybody's
eyes yes I would like if people can make
this a meme click this okay the
Coca-Cola zero you ordered is not zero
you are zero yeah that Coca-Cola has
zero sugars zero sugar in it okay and it
funds the Zionist uh uh government yes
who are doing atrocities you have zero
character bro you have zero character
the color you drink has zero sugar you
have zero character in you you have zero
Humanity left in you you have zero
heart I did not want to do this video I
don't like doing videos about individual
over and over over again yeah when I saw
this and he's doing this on a stream and
what does sneo say he said very clearly
and I I appreciate that did a little jab
boom he said yeah I'm boycotting no Cola
for me thank you very much now does this
mean that it is a matter of Halal Haram
I'm not saying that I'm not saying this
matter Hal you can choose not to boycott
understandable no problem that's you
okay you want yeah you taste no problem
no problem no one can blame you and say
you commit Haram but to mock it like you
did before with the other brother yes
the way you mock it yeah that is the
issue you mock those who do it and not
only that when you're ordering callor
you're smiling what's the smile about
you what what a what kind of individual
do you have to be how heartless you have
to be that you can say you know what I
choose to you know I just I believe the
boy doesn't do anything or Etc and
that's why and yeah and you can just
order off the stream but no no no alhamd
Allah is showing your true character
true phrase by your own tongue like he's
with the Israelis what the Israelis are
doing Subhan Allah the Zionist you
cannot make this up you cannot make this
up with their own tongue Allah subhana T
is showing their true face and for
everybody that for we have something
personal we have nothing personal we
have told you about this individuals
from the get goal so sneo may Allah
bless and preserve you for sticking to
the Bo inah and that's what I have to
say from sisters